the associate director of the summers
institute for the theory of computing
before we get started i wanted to go
over how to ask questions in today's
event
any time during the webinar you can
submit your questions
to the speaker using the q a button
just type your question into that window
and we'll get to as many questions as we
can during the
the q a session after the tour so the
simon's institute for the theory of
computing
is the leading venue for collaborative
research in theoretical computer science
it was established in 2012
with a grant from the simon's foundation
it brings together the world's leading
researchers in theoretical computer
science and related fields
as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars
to explore deep unsolved problems about
the nature and limits of computation
as well as promoting fundamental
research on the foundations of computer
science
the institute aims to expand the
horizons of the field by exploring other
scientific disciplines through a
computational lens
today's lecture is part of the
theoretically speaking series
that the institute hosts which it's a
series that highlights exciting advances
in theoretical computer science for a
public audience
and when we're not sheltering in place
these talks are held in downtown
berkeley with an audience from the
broader bay area community but of course
for now
our world is online only i'm delighted
to welcome our distinguished speaker
today uh professor michael kearns
michael holds the national center chair
in the computer and information science
department at the university of
pennsylvania
where he's been a professor since 2002
he has
secondary appointments in economics in
statistics
and in operations information decisions
he's
also an external faculty member with the
santa fe institute and since june this
year he's had a role in amazon as part
of his amazon scholars program
he's worked extensively in quantitative
and algorithmic trading on wall street
he serves as an advisor to technology
companies and venture capital firms
and he's involved in the seed stage fund
founder collective michael is a fellow
of the association for computing
machinery the association for the
advancement of artificial intelligence
the society for the advancement of
economic theory and the american academy
of arts and sciences
and of course michael has a strong
berkeley connection he was an undergrad
here at berkeley
and michael and i met in 1991 when he
was a postdoc here at ixe
his mentor was dick carp the founding
director of the simon's institute
so great to to have you back at least in
this online fashion
michael michael's talk today is on the
ethical algorithm which is also the
title of a book he's written with
aaron roth uh so very
excited to have you here and looking
forward to the talk welcome michael
um thanks very much can you see my
slides and hear me okay
we can yep okay great um thanks for the
introduction peter
and um welcome everybody thanks for
coming i saw the names of many
old friends and colleagues in the
participant list which is very nice to
see
um yeah so
late last year a book that my good
friend and colleague aaron roth at penn
and i wrote came out and it's called the
ethical algorithm
and kind of in keeping with this lecture
series
this is a a book about science written
for
a general lay audience um
and so what i want to do today is just
give you a snapshot
of kind of the topics in the book and
really this book is meant to be
a general audience representation of
what i think is a very important trend
going on in machine learning and
algorithms more generally and so the
subtitle is the science of socially
aware algorithm design
um let me tell you a little bit about
our motivation in writing this book
so as i'm sure many many people
in this talk um are aware
uh in recent years especially
following kind of the great excitement
about major advances in ai and machine
learning
in the first part of this decade largely
around applications in vision and speech
and powered by deep learning there's
been a bit of a
buzz kill or backlash as we have
gradually
realized that there are collateral
damages that can occur
in the deployment of sort of large-scale
ai and machine learning systems
and there are a number of good general
audience books on these topics perhaps
the most famous of them is weapons of
mass destruction
which kind of on a chapter by chapter
basis tells you about real ordinary
people
who've been harmed in different domains
by um
kind of misuses or abuses of machine
learning
um in you know everything from criminal
sentencing to
consumer lending to college admissions
to employment
um algorithms of oppression is about the
way
bias in society can be perpetuated by
search engines and search results
all you know again powered by machine
learning and by the collective data that
we generate for such systems
data and goliath is a great book about
um
sort of privacy and security in the
commercial surveillance age that we have
arrived at
and so um aaron and i like all these
books i think that they're important
interesting books but where we felt they
were lacking was when
they came to their solutions section so
every one of these books
does a very good job of identifying some
real problems
and then also usually towards the end
has a chapter on you know solutions what
should we
do about all this and and i might kind
of over characterize unfairly but i
think it's not
too far off the mark to say that each of
these books basically says well
we need better laws we need better
regulations we need
watchdog groups you know we really have
to keep an eye on all these problems
and let me just say at the outset that
you know my co-author and i agree with
that entirely
but as people who work in machine
learning and algorithm design
we know that there is another way also a
perhaps complementary way
which is that we don't like something
about the behavior of our algorithms as
they stand now
we could think about just changing the
algorithm in the first place
okay um so rather than you know
just doing things as we normally do them
and waiting for harms to occur and then
litigating them or regulating them after
the fact
we could think about trying to design
our algorithms in a different way and
prevent those harms
or at least mitigate those harms in the
first place
and it would have been easy to kind of
say that if it were not for
the very large amount of research that
has taken place
in the last 10 years in the machine
learning and largely
theoretical computer science communities
on exactly those topics so
we kind of felt like the time was right
to kind of tell
a larger world than the community of
people that we talk to all the time
already
about what was going on in that
discipline
and you know just so we're all on the
same page here at the beginning
the research agenda that we described in
this book um
seeks to actually you know precisely
define
and actually embed social norms or
values
in algorithms so literally the idea is
if i can be precise enough about what i
mean by a concept like privacy
or a concept like fairness um so precise
that i could you know
write it down mathematically and then
impose it as a constraint
in my python code um then
in principle we could have algorithms
that behave better
with respect to the types of problems
that the books on my last slide
clearly identify now
depending on exactly what social norm we
have in mind
um you know this this can be easier said
than done
but um especially in this lecture series
one point i'd like to make at the outset
is that perhaps the most important part
of this enterprise is the very first
step
which is being exceedingly precise about
definitions
and in case you know nobody knew this
already
computer scientists are far from the
first community of people
to have ever thought carefully about
things like fairness privacy
and the like um i mean in the case of
fairness it goes back
at least to the ancient philosophers and
through modern times you know recent
communities that have thought
quite deeply about things like fairness
include
obviously moral philosophers legal
scholars economists and many many others
but the truth is that none of those
communities have ever
or have ever wanted or needed to be
again
so precise about what they meant by a
notion such as fairness
that you could literally embed it in
your
in your code okay and one
point that we make early in the book um
you know kind of speaking
very much from our roots as theoretical
computer scientists
is that one of the values of that
enterprise
is that you know sometimes by thinking
very very hard about the right
definition
for something um you you will uncover
flaws in
your intuitions about these things that
you weren't going to discover any other
way
okay and i'll give a couple of examples
as we go along
and again because this is a series about
theoretical computer science for a more
general audience
i might make the additional remark that
um
you know there are many areas of
computer science
where the theory is interesting but not
particularly necessary for the advance
of the you know the empirical side of
the discipline
so you know peter and i and many others
on this call have
worked our entire careers on theoretical
topics in machine learning
and there's a lot of interesting
practical results in
that body of theoretical work but the
thing about machine learning is you know
even if you even if you don't have a
definition of what learning means
um and even in the presence of
interactive intractability results that
tell you that the most basic machine
learning
problems should be hard in the worst
case there's nothing preventing you from
getting data and going out and trying it
and seeing
if it works on your data set and if it
does you know if you build a model that
has good predictive accuracy
you don't really need any theory to tell
you why it works or exactly what
definition of learning that it means
but when we're talking about actually
trying to encode
in an algorithm what you mean by
something like fairness
or privacy and what promises that that
definition is going to give to
individuals
um the stakes are kind of much higher
for getting definitions right
okay because you know you're going to go
out and do something and it's going to
make choices that might let's say
favor one group or harm another group
and it's not so easy to just say well
let's just try it and see what happens
in some sense that's kind of what got us
into this mess in the first place right
is
kind of people just saying like well i'm
just going to run you know
stochastic gradient descent on a deep
convolutional neural network
on this large consumer data set and you
know what could possibly go wrong
well there's a you know at least the
books on the last slide that i showed
you
to tell you what could go wrong with
that and so
you know not to go on too long about
this i think that this is an area
where because definitions are very
important and understanding the
consequences of those
definitions is very important the
relative um
kind of importance of theory is much
much higher
so so but you know at a high level the
summary of our book
is to survey recent research um around
the topic of ethical algorithms meaning
being precise what you mean by
these social values or norms and then
the consequences of implementing those
in your algorithms um and
the book is roughly arranged at least in
the first half of the book
around different social norms so you
know
there's an early chapter on privacy
there's an early chapter on algorithmic
fairness
um and i've written a bunch of social
norms
here that you know if you traffic in the
ai and ml community have become
uh quite topical um and you'll notice
that they're written in increasing
you know in increasingly fading text
here
and and that fading text is meant to
represent our subjective view
of how scientifically mature each of
these areas is
at the time that we wrote the book so
for instance our feeling is that
the study of algorithmic privacy and
specifically differential privacy is
perhaps the most
scientifically mature of these areas
fairness we think is maybe a decade
behind but off to a solid start
things like interpretability or
explainability
we think are very important topics but
we think that
um we're quite far from being on firm
scientific footing there
in the sense that you know again in our
opinion
um good good general definitions
of these notions have not yet been given
if there's time
at the end or in the q a i can maybe say
a little bit more about
why we feel that way um but but so what
i want to do in the rest of the talk
is is just kind of give you a couple of
vignettes
one around privacy and the other one
around fairness
and in each of these vignettes i'm going
to first of all
observe how it's possible to be very
very precise about
a definition for what you mean by
something like privacy or fairness
and to get it entirely wrong right so in
other words
being precise isn't by itself enough
obviously
it's possible to give very precise even
actionable definitions
that are kind of the wrong ones for
various reasons and i'm going to you
know
give examples of that both for privacy
and also for fairness
and in each of those cases you know that
that will lead to sort of
alternative definitions of privacy
fairness or whatever
that seem closer to the right definition
or at least a better definition
okay and along the way i'll try to give
kind of case studies and examples of
both what's known about these topics
from a scientific theoretical standpoint
and a little bit about
where we stand with respect to
deployment of these ideas
in fielded systems and also kind of
how all of these scientific topics do or
do not play well
with the current state of our our laws
and regulations in the us
and the eul and elsewhere
so let me first talk about data privacy
um
so there's a now famous quote due to
cynthia dork
which simply goes as anonymized data
isn't
and basically this is meant as a
critique of
the set of techniques which are you know
if if there's one type of privacy notion
which is in the most
widespread use and deployment and is
most pervasive in our laws
it is based around things like
anonymization or
you know eradicating pii personally
identifiable information
and um cynthia's quote is meant to
basically say
either you haven't done enough
anonymization and so the data actually
isn't anonymized at all
or you've done so much of it that it
isn't really data anymore in the sense
of it being useful for anything
okay so what's the idea behind
anonymization well
the vague idea behind anonymization is i
start with some
database let's say like this toy medical
database
um on the upper half of this slide and i
decide well look you know
this is valuable data i'd like to be
able to share this data outside of the
confines of this hospital maybe
it's the hospital of the university of
pennsylvania i'd like to share with
scientists i maybe want to pool
my data set with other hospitals to get
a more
a broader demographic representation but
it's sensitive data each row of this
database is somebody's actual medical
record
so what i'm going to go in and do is i'm
going to you know give myself kind of
two different operations redaction and
coursing
so i'm going to allow myself to go into
like the name column and say
you know it's not really important what
somebody's name is
to you know build a predictive model for
what their diagnosis is or for a rare
disease
so i'm just going to eradicate that
entirely
age might be relevant in disease
prediction
but i don't want to put down people's
exact age because i might be able to
re-identify
individual records that way so i'm going
to group that into
you know um blocks of 10 years i'm going
to keep gender
i'm going to redact the last two digits
of zip code etc okay
and you know the high level idea behind
anonymization is that if i do enough of
this but not too much of it
the database will still be useful for
something like you know
building predictive models for rare
diseases but
i shouldn't be able to go in and kind of
squint at this
anonymized database and kind of be able
to reconstruct
the actual medical record of real people
so in particular the kind of thing we'd
like to avoid is if i have some
additional information outside of this
anonymized database like
i have a female neighbor i know her name
is rebecca and that she's 57 years old
i shouldn't be able to go into this
database knowing perhaps that she is a
patient at this hospital
and figure out which medical record is
hers
and so indeed if i look at this database
and take what i know about my neighbor
rebecca
well her name is missing from the
database that's been redacted
and there are two records that match
what i know about my neighbor that she's
57 years old and female
and so you know because of this
anonymization i have some
confusion about which of these two rows
might be my neighbor's
medical record i would point out to you
that already
my you know from just narrowing it down
to these two records i know that my
neighbor
either has hiv or colitis which she
might well
consider to be a violation of her
privacy already
um but we might hope to wish this a way
by saying well in a real
database um there might be 10 000 such
records and i might do enough
anonymization and redaction
that you know for any particular row
that i knew something about
there would be at least 100 other rows
that match not just
two rows that match okay and in fact
this is one of the formal
definitions of anonymity so the the
definition of k
anonymity means that i do enough
redaction and coarsening
such that if you go in and you know look
look at the rows or a subset of the rows
for instance
then anything that matches you know a
subset
that a particular row or a subset of the
columns
um there will be at least k other
matches in the database so
i will be kind of k confused about which
row belongs to my neighbor rebecca
okay okay so um
this doesn't seem unreasonable but there
are serious
kind of irreparable problems with it
okay
so so one one of them is kind of more
conceptual
which is i've given you like a syntactic
definition of theories i basically say
you know you meet can anonymity if this
property of the database holds
but i haven't really told you as an
individual
why you should think that that's a
satisfying guarantee of privacy
okay so it's entirely syntactic it's not
like a semantic
guarantee at all okay but but the
problem is actually much worse than that
or the fact that i
can infer things like my neighbor is
either hiv or has colitis
the the real kind of you know moral
problem with anonymization techniques
is that they pretend like the database
that you are anonymizing
is the only data set that will ever
exist now
or in perpetuity and as soon as that
kind of threat model is violated which
basically
it you know is everywhere all the time
in the real world these days
um all bets are wrong so in particular
um at the top i i've shown you a two
anonymous database if you project on to
the fields of
name age gender and zip code any if you
carefully verified it
for any values of those four attributes
in the top database there are at least
two rows that match
and the bottom database is similarly
three anonymous
okay but if i take the join of these two
databases and what i know about my
neighbor rebecca
then from the top of the database i know
she has either hiv or colitis from the
bottom i know she has
hiv lupus or a hip fracture and from the
joint i know
unambiguously that she has hiv okay
so whatever promise i gave you about
say anonymity in the presence of an
isolated anonymized database
that that promise is you know incredibly
brittle
in the sense that just joining two
databases that both meet the property
can eradicate all privacy guarantees
whatsoever
okay so so this is an example of a
precise but broken definition
again unfortunately to the extent that
our laws and regulations are ever very
precise about what they mean
by privacy they usually mean exactly
this kind of broken notion so
hipaa which is the body of law governing
health care in the united states
bakes in notions of anonymity left and
right so
you know in some ways this is even worse
than not being precise at all
because you've committed precisely to
something that is broken
okay and you know this is going to take
some time to undo
and i think will have to be undone
eventually okay
so i'm curmudging and complaining about
one definition of privacy
so what would be a better definition of
privacy well
if the problem with the the notion
things like k
anonymity is that they're too weak from
a privacy perspective
let me give you another definition
that's flawed in the opposite direction
which is that it's too strong
meaning that if we adopted this notion
of privacy
we would essentially not be able to make
valuable societal
or commercial use of data so
what's the definition of privacy i have
in mind so
i could make this precise but i don't
think i need to
um imagine i you know you have your
medical record and i'm asking whether
you would be willing to contribute your
medical record
to some valuable study that i'm hoping
to perform
okay and you have privacy concerns
and suppose i told you well look
whatever you're worried about
the chances of that happening to you um
you know as a result of this study and
your inclusion of the day your data in
this study
um are nim it just won't happen right
whatever whatever harm you're worried
about um
you know if i compare not doing the
study at all
or doing the study with your data the
chances that the bad thing you're
worried about happens to you
in those two scenarios are identical or
negligibly different
okay so i might call this the no harm
whatsoever
definition of privacy no harm whatsoever
because you know compared to not doing
the study at all
whatever harm you're worried about is
not going to increase and you can define
whatever you consider to be the harm
that you're worried about
okay so what i'm showing you on this
slide
is the cover page in the first of a very
famous series of articles conducted by
the british
physicians doll in hell in the 1950s
doll and hill were the um
dollar hill were the british researchers
who first firmly established a strong
connection between
smoking and lung cancer and so in 1950
or so
they asked every physician in the uk
whether they would opt in
to their studies and two-thirds of the
doctors in the uk
opted in so they had a very large data
set okay
and and so you know not long after
they got the data you know they did some
basic correlations and found wow
there's a high statistically significant
correlation between smoking lung cancer
and they started writing a series of
articles like this okay
so imagine you were a physician in the
uk
in 1950 and you were contemplating
contributing to this study
and let's say for the sake of argument
that you were a smoker
and in 1950 probably you were a smoker
because
in the 1950s almost everybody smoked
at least in westernized nations it was
not
there was no social or medical stigma
associated with it
it was actually seen as glamorous by the
way um
my parents met as graduate students at
berkeley
and got married at international house
and one of the things they told me at
some point was that you know
smoking in the late 50s at berkeley was
rampant
and you would be in a lecture hall like
in the hall or something in a physics
lecture
and the entire room would be just like a
cloud
a haze of smoke you could barely see the
blackboard if you weren't sitting close
and furthermore the instructor would be
chained smoking during the lecture
okay so so like smoking was no big deal
in 1950 and so
you might have been as well as smoker
and you wouldn't have been hiding this
fact it would have been kind of
public knowledge to people that knew you
at least
okay okay so now i suppose you
contributed your medical record to this
study
well real harm could have come to you as
a result of this study
right because you know now the world
knows about this strong
connection between smoking and lung
cancer people know that you're a smoker
so everybody's posterior belief that you
might have lung cancer goes up
possibly including your health insurer
who might decide to raise your premium
so we could literally say
that actual financial harm resulted
to you from your contribution of your
medical record to this study and so
this no harm whatsoever definition would
preclude
valuable uses of data like this
okay so that seems like it's going too
far
but the two worlds that i compared in
this definition
actually contain the seed of like the
escape hatch
to you know like what we and many many
others think is the right
notion of privacy and and the
observation is the following
in the no harm whatsoever definition i
consider two different worlds
i do the study with your medical record
included
or i don't do the study at all okay
but if you think about it in the dolan
hill study
it's not as if your medical record was
the
crucial piece of data that allowed them
to discover the link between smoking and
lung cancer
like any sufficiently large data set of
smokers and non-smokers
would have made this fact glaringly
obvious to dollar hill
okay so the point is that the link
between smoking and lung cancer
isn't actually something about your
private data
it is a fact about the world that can be
discovered from any
sufficiently large data set and so we
want a definition that somehow
carves out these facts about the world
and doesn't count them as like your
private data
even though of course collectively we
need enough people's private data
to discover these facts about the world
okay
and so this leads to the now famous
influential definition of differential
privacy
which you can think of as just a slight
but incredibly important variation
on the no harm whatsoever rather than
comparing
you know doing the study with your data
or not doing the study at all
we're going to compare doing the study
with your data
and still doing the study but just
without only your data
we're going to compare two different
databases as inputs to the study
one consisting of end medical records
including yours
and one with n minus one medical records
where you are the minus one
and um the high level idea behind
differential privacy
is that an algorithm obeys differential
privacy it's a property by the way of an
algorithm not of a data set for
resistance
an algorithm is differentially private
if
a third-party observer only looking at
the output of the algorithm
cannot reliably distinguish whether the
input did or did not
include your data in a statistical sense
okay
and if you think about it this is kind
of the right definition
because you know if we take it as an
axiom which
we think we should that if your data set
wasn't
with your data wasn't even included in
the inputs
then the output can't possibly violate
your privacy
well if somebody can't tell the
difference between whether your data was
in the input or
out or not then still your privacy
can't be violated okay and so when you
look at the technical definition of
differential privacy which i won't give
you'll you'll see that
to meet differential privacy in an
interesting way
um importantly requires the use of
randomization
like the algorithms need to in the way
you achieve differential privacy
is through the tasteful injection of
noise
into computations at particular points
in the computation
and you basically ask that the
distribution over outputs
induced by that noise or randomization
be controllably close
and importantly differential privacy
does have a knob
which lets you say how strong the
promised
individual privacy is and there is
always going to be a trade-off between
kind of the utility or the accuracy of
the results you get
and the amount of noise you add or the
amount of privacy that you're promising
so to demystify this a little bit let me
give the earliest example of a
differentially private
algorithm or protocol which
interestingly
predates the definition of differential
privacy by about 40 years
okay and this is a survey method from
the social psychology literature known
as randomized response
okay so the idea of randomized response
is
the it is to truthfully elicit from a
population
answers to a question that may have a
socially stigmatizing answer
okay so to put a modern twist on this
suppose i wanted to survey the
population of philadelphia
a large population um with the question
have you violated social distancing
guidelines
in the last six months okay and we might
imagine
that if i ask this question straight up
right that even if i send people to
anonymous website they might worry that
i'm tracking them
and since there's a potential social
stigma with one of the possible answers
namely
um yes i have violated social distancing
guidelines
if i just ask the question in a
straightforward way
i might get a massive under reporting of
yes answers and so i would have sort of
you know no way of really computing a
good estimate of the fraction of
philadelphians that have violated social
distancing guidelines
so what do you do in randomized response
instead well so in randomized response
what i ask you to do is i say like look
um the question is have you violated
social distancing guidelines
but the way i want you to respond is as
follows
i want you to flip a coin let's say a
fair coin 50
heads and tails um if it comes up heads
i want you to just answer the question
truthfully yes or no have you violated
social distancing guidelines
on the other hand if the coin comes up
tails then i want you to flip the coin
again and just to use the outcome of the
second coin flip to answer
so if you know if you if the coin comes
up tails the first time then you flip it
again if it comes up heads you say
yes i've violated social distancing
guidelines
regardless of whether you have or not
and if the second question
comes up tables you say no regardless of
what your truth is
okay so this protocol has a couple of
very interesting nice properties
first of all forgetting even about the
definition of differential privacy it
has a very strong
sense of plausible deniability
right because even if i attribute your
response to you and let's say
peter says to me yes i violated social
distancing guidelines according to this
protocol
i can confront him and say are you crazy
you know are you trying to kill us all
and peter can say oh no
no no i haven't really violated social
distancing guidelines
just when i flipped the coin it came the
first one came up tails and the second
one came up heads okay
so every single person that answers yes
simultaneously has plausible deniability
for their yes answer
they can credibly say that their truth
was the opposite
okay at an individual but if everybody
follows this protocol faithfully
it's pretty easy to see that you can
back out if you have a large population
a very accurate estimate
of the true fraction of philadelphians
who have violated social distancing
guidelines okay
because under the values of the model of
the param the parameters that i've set
here
you have a three-quarters chance of
answering whatever your truth is and a
one-quarter chance of answering the
opposite
and so i can just write down a simple
you know equation
for what the you know kind of s my
maximum likelihood estimate
of the true fraction of violators is
okay
and more generally right if instead of
asking you to flip a fair coin i ask you
to use like a dungeons and drag
dragon dice so i can generate more
refined values for the probabilities
i could ask you to answer truthfully
with probability p
and to flip a fair coin to answer with
probability one minus p
and of course if i make the the smaller
and smaller i may p
the more i'm directing you to use a coin
flip to answer
the more privacy you have but the more
noise there is in my estimate
whereas if i make p bigger and bigger
and i'm directing you to answer
truthfully more often
you have a weaker privacy guarantee but
i have less noise and therefore a more
accuracy
and so this is the idea behind
differential privacy
differential privacy spent a good 10
years in the laboratory or
more accurately on the whiteboard and
before in the last five years it started
to see
first kind of playful deployments in the
tech industry and gradually more serious
so what i'm showing you here is a
screenshot from a google site
that basically publishes differentially
private
heat maps of um of
of activity in metropolitan areas so you
know
by heat map i mean using gps
location data from android phones
um google compiles statistics on what
parts of philadelphia for instance
people are gathering in uncomfortably
large numbers
in uncomfortably close proximity for
uncomfortably long periods of time
and publishing them so in just in case
anybody
who goes to those places maybe wants to
rethink that
or if you don't go to those places maybe
you want to avoid them
um but they know of course that this is
being built from very sensitive private
granular data about geo-location so they
release these heat maps under the
promise of differential privacy
and there are enough people in places
like philadelphia
that they can still produce useful
statistics
while still giving strong prop uh
privacy promises
the real moon shot for differential
privacy is coming up even as we speak
the 2020 u.s census which actually has a
congressional
mandate to um obey privacy
considerations in the release of
statistics from the census
but up until the last 10 years nobody
had a good definition of what that meant
so all previous censuses used kind of ad
hoc anonymous
non-ministerization techniques that were
highly subject to
you know re-identification attacks
this year they're promising that every
single statistic released
from the u2020 census will in fact
um be released in a differentially
private manner
with ie with noise added and this is not
without
drawbacks or controversy so here's a new
york times op-ed
kind of arguing that because of the
noise added especially small communities
might have an amount of noise added to
their census counts
which effectively disappears them or
greatly underestimates their true
population
which is what you need to do in order to
get privacy
um but since these counts are in fact
used for federal budgeting decisions and
allocations
this could have real potential harms um
to those communities i i should note
that the
authors of this op-ed are also
demographers who
um whose careers are basically based on
the types of uh census data that have
been released in previous years so they
they have a vested interest in perhaps
differential privacy
not being enforced in the 2020 census
okay um so let me say a little bit about
fairness
um so as i said at the outset the study
of algorithmic fairness
is still very much a work in progress um
we we already know that the study of
algorithmic fairness will be
messier than the study of privacy so you
know i've i've argued here without
proof but you know you can go read more
yourself in our book or elsewhere about
about why many people have gravitated
towards differential privacy as
kind of a monolithic single right
definition
of privacy um we already know there's
not going to be such a thing
in the case of albert mcfarris so in
particular
um in recent years there have been a
number of papers that essentially
um give what we might call like arrows
and possibility theorems for fairness
for those of you with an econ background
so these are papers that basically say
um look
you know why do we have so many
definitions of fairness in the
literature why don't we unify this into
one
stronger definition that gives us
everything we want simultaneously
and so the paper says well let's take a
maximum approach you know
you you know here are three properties
that you would want any good definition
of fairness to me right and you know you
the reader
look at these three properties and you
say yes yes you know
these are incredibly weak properties i
would definitely want these three
properties to hold and probably other
ones as well
and then of course the punchline of the
paper is a theorem proving
that except in trivial unrealistic
situations
you cannot simultaneously achieve those
three properties
okay so we already know that there might
be incompatibilities between different
notions
of fairness and even within a given
notion of fairness there will be
trade-offs between
accuracy and fairness just the way there
are trade-offs between
accuracy and privacy and differential
privacy and it can even be worse than
that it could really even be
that with respect to a particular
definition of fairness like equalizing
the error rates of a
of a model that i've learned across
different demographic
groups that asking for more equality by
gender means that i have to have less
equality by race there can there really
are data sets
where that tension exists and that's
just like a fact of life or science that
we have to get used to and we
need as a society to for you know to to
make difficult choices about these
trade-offs
but before i get too far let me just
give you like a toy
yet realistic example of how it is that
sort of the the vanilla standard
classical principles of machine learning
um will you should expect them to result
in models that are unfair in in
ways that we can quantify okay um so let
me give this example
so suppose aaron and i were asked by
the university of pennsylvania
admissions office to help them develop a
predictive model from past admissions
data on
what high school applicants depend will
succeed in college
okay and just to make this simple and
visual
let's imagine we're trying to predict
collegiate success from only two
variables
an applicant's high school grade point
average on the x-axis
and their sat score on the y-axis okay
and so each green
point here has an x-coordinate
representing that applicant's high
school gpa and a y
coordinate representing their sat score
and i'm imagining that what were
the data set that we have here is not
only on students that were admitted to
pen
but that actually matriculated that came
to pen okay
so because they were accepted and they
attended penn
we know whether they succeeded in
hindsight and for success let's use any
quantitative objectively measurable
definition that you like
let's say um graduated within five years
of starting with at least a 3.0 gpa and
so the plus screen points
indicate the people who succeeded
according to that criterion the minus
indicated the people who didn't succeed
okay
and even without knowing anything about
machine learning if i ask you to eyeball
this cloud of data points
and use it to build a predictive model
that we could apply to future applicants
of pen
you might very well choose this blue
linear classifier where we're going to
predict that any point that's
above this blue line is going to succeed
and anybody below this blue line is not
going to succeed
and you'll see that it does a pretty
good job of separating pluses from
minuses it's not perfect it makes some
it makes some false positives right
these are the students
who actually who would have been
accepted by this model
that in fact failed at penn
and it makes some false rejections these
are students
who did in fact succeed historically
that this model would have rejected
but it but it does a pretty good job and
if you looked carefully you would see
that this
is the linear classifier which
minimizes the error on the historical
data okay which is
the you know to a first approximation is
like the common criteria for machine
learning you have some
training data set and you want to
minimize the error on that training data
set
okay well suppose i told you that this
cloud of points was not the entire data
set but that there was another
subgroup of applicants that i'll call
the oranges and here are the orange data
points and there's a few things i want
you to notice about the origins
first of all the oranges are a minority
group in the literal sense that there
are far
fewer of them than there were of the
green points
secondly there seems to be something
different about the distribution of the
orange points
in particular their sat scores seem to
be systematically lower
the orange cloud just looks kind of
shifted down compared to the green cloud
okay
and i might i might offer a reason for
that
maybe the green applicants are from a
wealthy demographic
and that wealthy demographic has the
time and the money
to pay for sat tutoring courses and
multiple retakes of the exam
submitting the best scores to penn the
orange population can't afford that they
are going to high school and working a
job to support their
family so they just do a bit of
self-study they take the exam once and
they
they take whatever scores they get but
despite their sat scores being
lower it is not the case that the
oranges are less
qualified to succeed at penn if you had
counted carefully in the
green cloud you would have found that
slightly
less than half of the green cloud were
pluses
whereas exactly half of the orange cloud
are pluses so the oranges
appear to be slightly more qualified for
success
than the greens and if i ask you to
build a classifier just for the oranges
you might well pick this purple line
which actually does a perfect job on the
data
of separating pluses from minuses so you
can see where this is heading
the problem arises when i look at the
combined cloud and if i just use the
standard
time-honored principle of minimizing the
error on the overall data sets
i am unfortunately forced to choose the
same classifier i would have on the
green alone
and the reason is that if i try to move
this blue classifier down
far enough to pick up these five orange
pluses
i will pick up so many more green
minuses
along the way that my overall era will
increase significantly
okay so we have a situation where the
standard principle of machine learning
will by definition lead us to a model
with low error
but now we can also quantify the sense
in which this model is unfair
if i if i if i pause it that the
greatest harm that can occur
in college admissions is false rejection
rather than false acceptance although i
could argue that
it's not great to be accepted to some
place that you're not going to succeed
but if i really think as the main
injustice or harm that i'm trying to
prevent
is false rejections well this model
which maximizes the overall predictive
accuracy on the data
also is maximally unfair in the sense
that the false rejection rate
on the orange population is a hundred
percent
and the false rejection rate on the
green population
is close to zero okay
now you might say to me well this is
silly why don't
i if i'm able to measure on the app if i
ask on the application whether you're a
green or an
orange why don't i just use this
two-part model which says well if you're
from the green
i'm going to apply the blue model and if
you're from the
orange i'm going to apply the purple one
okay
and if i did that not only would i erase
the disparity in false rejection rates
i would also improve my overall accuracy
unfortunately once again to the extent
that we have
laws that are precise about what
fairness means let's say in the united
states
if as i've suggested or invited you to
believe that orange
and green correlate or
are are or either are strongly
correlated with race
this type of two-part model is
explicitly forbidden
because it looks at race as an input and
for instance in consumer lending in the
united states
it is forbidden to use race as an input
and so this is an example
where you know i'm sure that people who
enacted these laws were well intentioned
but it was again kind of like
anonymity it was this magical thinking
like oh
somehow if i don't let you look at race
in your modeling process
you can't possibly be unfair by race so
this example
is a case where in fact
forbidding the use of racism input to
the model
ensures harm to the very group that you
thought you were protecting by
forbidding the use of race in the first
place
okay and so we argue in the book the
definitions of fairness that try to get
fairness by restricting the inputs to an
algorithm
or to a machine learning model are like
k anonymity
fundamentally flawed and broken and
unfortunately encoded in many bodies of
law
and the way you should do instead is use
definitions of fairness
that simply say what you want at the
output not at the input
so go ahead and use anything you want
use race use people's social media data
to make lending decisions but don't
discriminate don't have
models that have widely different false
acceptance or rejection rates on
different demographic
groups that you care to protect okay
but notice is a byproduct of this little
vignette we now
do have a precise definition of fairness
and and many of the definitions of
fairness that are in wide use have this
form
what is that definition of fairness
rather than the usual
criteria of find the model the linear
classifier the deep neural network
whatever you want that minimizes the
overall error on the data
solve instead of that optimization
problem solve a constrained optimization
problem
and that constrained optimization
problem is minimize the overall
error on the data subject to the
condition
that let's say the false rejection rate
between
these two groups has to be
zero or less than one percent or less
than five percent or less than 25
and so once again as with differential
privacy i have a knob on this definition
if i set that knob to zero then i'm
prioritizing fairness over everything
else including predictive accuracy
if i let the disparity between false
rejection rates be five percent
i'm still asking for you know a strong
notion of fairness of this type at least
but now i have some wiggle room to
optimize the error
if i back off and let the disparity be a
hundred percent then it's like i didn't
ask for any fairness at all
and so you can go to actual data sets
and implement
algorithms that solve these types of
constrained optimization problems
and you can plot out pareto curves of
this kind so what am i showing you here
on some real data set in which fairness
is a concern
on the x-axis i'm showing you the error
of the model on the overall data set
and on the y-axis i'm showing you the
unfairness of the model
according to some measure like the
difference between false rejection rates
across racial groups okay and each
little red dot
on this curve is a different model think
of it as being like a different linear
classifier
on the toy data set in the example that
i just gave
and you can see right you have a clear
trade-off here
you can either ignore fairness entirely
and just go for minimizing error
in which case you'll get this model
which has the lowest error value but the
highest unfairness value
you can ask to turn that knob all the
way to zero percent disparity in false
rejection rates
and and get to zero unfairness at
considerably higher error
and in between you can get you'll get in
between okay
and so i'll make two comments about this
in some sense this is kind of as far as
the science can take us
in the sense that like you know a
computer scientist like me
shouldn't be looking at a curve like
this and telling the pen admissions
like this is what i should give to the
pen admissions office
i shouldn't give this to the pen
admissions office and say like and this
is the place you want to be on this
curve
because that's like a that's a
qualitative decision that's like a moral
decision
that a stakeholder who really thinks
carefully
about the balance between fairness and
accuracy and college admissions
or criminal sentencing or whatever it is
should make
okay so that's sort of point one number
one
point number two is that you know
probably not too many people in this
audience but when we wait out amongst
other groups that can include regulators
sometimes
they sometimes want to disavow figures
like this at all and they say like oh
well you know
i don't want to be anywhere on this
picture at all i find it distasteful to
be asked
to quantify my relative value for
fairness versus accuracy
and and you know our answer to that is
probably obvious to many of you which is
like
sure you can be somewhere else other
than on this curve
and where that somewhere else is going
to be is over here somewhere
right because this is the pareto
frontier this is the set of like
undominated models
in this two dimensional objective space
of fairness and accuracy
and if you ignore it you ignore it at
your peril because you're likely to
pick a model over here which is one that
can be
improved on both fairness and accuracy
by moving to a model that's on the
on the efficient frontier okay
so i'm running out of time so let me
just
let me just say a little bit more about
the second half of the book so what i
what i the things like what i've told
you so far mainly occupy the first half
of the book
the second half of the book takes what
we think is an interesting left
turn and so so i won't go into much
detail but i'll tell you the nature of
the left turn
i've invited you in everything i've said
so far
and all the books that i pointed to at
the beginning also invite you to think
this way
to think of ordinary people as being the
victims of algorithms and
models and machine learning so you know
somebody
builds this big predictive model from
our collective data
and now this model is making lending
decisions criminal sentencing decisions
called
admissions decisions and inflicting you
know measurable real harm on
ordinary people and even worse these
ordinary people might not even realize
that this is happening they may not know
that they were rejected from
a load by a neural network for example
in the second half of the book we think
about situations in which
algorithms again and often you know more
specifically
models that are the output of a machine
learning process
are central but it's not quite so easy
to entirely blame the algorithm
because the algorithm or perhaps more
accurately the app
is actually mediating the possibly
competing preferences of a large
population
of users okay so just to give you a
little bit of flavor of what i mean by
that
you know the most standard example would
be um
the most standard example the easiest
example to think about are navigation
apps like google maps and waze
so on the one hand what could possibly
be better right
instead of like you know the old days of
fold up maps
and you know hourly traffic reports on
the radio
i just punch in i'm here i want to go
here what you know and in response to
the real-time
gps traffic data from like all of our
phones
the app tells me here's your shortest
driving route
okay and so like this is great i'll
admit i i
you know i don't i don't go anywhere you
know that i don't know the way very well
in the traffic patterns already without
using these apps
but but if you back up for a second you
know what's really going on with these
apps
is that we we are playing some
incredibly
complicated multiplayer game right
it's it's a game in the literal game
theoretic sense and that each of us has
a utility function right i want to go
from here to there
and my objective is to minimize my
driving time usually
okay and all of you have similar utility
functions
okay and what these apps are doing
is helping us compute our best responses
in response to what everybody else is
doing here is your best response
and so in that sense these apps are
nudging us towards
a competitive equilibrium literally they
are nudging us towards a nash
equilibrium
and again any of you who've ever been
exposed to even a little bit of game
theory will know
that just because we're at an
equilibrium of some kind
doesn't mean not only does it not mean
that we're not collectively better off
it doesn't necessarily mean that any one
of us individually is off right so
tragedy of the commons um or prisoners
dilemma
are kind of good examples of this okay
and so in the second half of the book we
we sort of talk about situations and it
includes things like recommendation
systems
and and you know filtering of your
facebook news feed
and shopping recommendations and things
like this
um we think about these settings where
our collective data
is being used to optimize or personalize
something for us
and you know what type of equilibrium
it's driving us towards and whether
we're happy or not with it
and and again in the spirit of the book
and the research it describes
we talk about algorithmic solutions like
how might you
how might you for instance modify
navigation apps
in a way that for instance still gives
us kind of the benefits of them largely
that we've come to know and love
but without sort of driving us towards
equilibria that might be collectively
causing us
to spend more time commuting than we
actually need to
in some other non-equilibrium solution
okay
and that's sort of the subject of the
second half of the book
okay so let me um let me stop there and
um leave plenty of time for q a
hopefully
fantastic thanks michael that was really
fascinating and and very
very accessible so yes we'll take we'll
take um
questions from the audience please use
the q a feature
uh type your questions into into that
there's there's already half a dozen
there
uh michael of about half of them seem to
be on the privacy
direction um
uh so so maybe i'll let me
let me uh rebound out to you so the
first one is
do you think it would be ethical to set
up an economic model where you offer
rewards to people to incentivize them to
make their data public
the idea is to let people choose if they
want their data to be included in the
data set and take the risk of losing
their privacy
okay so that's a great idea and i think
that that's a great idea that
deserves research we tried to think
about that a little bit a few years ago
and it quickly gets difficult but also
interesting and let me try to swap back
in a couple
of reasons why um
so so one one thing that you immediately
face
um is
you know so i think if i understand the
question correctly it's like
you know maybe differential privacy
could be
used or some other mechanism could be
used
to kind of decide what the fair price
for people's individual data was
um with respect to like its contribution
to a
to a computation and and so one
one kind of i don't know if paradox is
the right word but one one problem that
immediately arises is
suppose i'm trying to build a predictive
model for a very rare disease
okay so you know
it's easy for me to get the medical
records of people
who don't have the rare disease because
they don't have the rare you know
there's a lot of them first of all
and you know they don't have the rare
disease so there's nothing particular at
least with respect to this prediction
there's nothing particularly
stigmatizing but i also need to
incentivize the people with the rare
disease and a fair number of them
probably far out of proportion to their
actual rate in the population at large
okay so i need to figure out how to do
that differential
processing and of course the people who
have the rare disease who are the most
valuable to this computation
also probably have the greatest privacy
concerns right so let's say the
background rate of this disease is
you know one in ten thousand and i might
want to create for machine learning
purposes a balanced
data set of 50 50 disease and
non-disease okay
and so then when you think about it like
well even if i could incentivize the
people
who have the rare disease to contribute
despite the higher
social risk for them now that i've
created this 50 50 balanced data set
if i just tell you if i just tell you
that somebody's
data is in the data set just from that
fact your posterior belief
about them having the disease is you
know
many many times greater than the
background rate of the population so
even if you don't have the disease
and you're in this 50 50 balanced data
set because
it's 50 50 and the background rate is
one in a million or one in 10 000 or
whatever
and so we kind of got stuck thinking
both from a differential privacy lens
and more generally
about how you handle these kinds of
conundrums from a pricing perspective
but i i do think
that that idea of of
you know using something like
differential privacy as a basis
for for a market for private data is an
interesting one
um and understood
great the next one says what if you were
the tallest person in your city and the
study gives the range of
heights of participants uh a range that
doesn't include your height so say
you're six foot five
inches and the range is four foot to six
foot then say it make
makes conclusions that everyone who
knows you will not apply to you
can it still violate your privacy
let's see um i'm reading this if you're
the tallest person
and the study gives the range um
i i i understand the purpose of the
question but i'm i'm
i'm trying to make it precise in the
language of differential privacy i mean
um
if by the range four to six feet you
mean literally that's the min
and the max um
[Music]
and and people know that you're 6'5
i mean the only thing that they could
infer about you is that you were not
contained in the data set
right and so i don't i think this is
outside of the purview of differential
privacy
because differential privacy basically
only demands that
it the indistinguishable um
whether you were weren't in the data set
which i guess i would be able to infer
that you're not
i'd have to think about it i don't
immediately see that
um differential privacy
provides protections in this case
right i mean i guess i would see the
question of saying uh
can your privacy be violated
by um you know it being widely known
that you are not
a participant in some particular study
or you're not present in a data set
yeah yeah i don't think i don't think
this violates differential privacy
but i don't if if if
the if alexi thinks that you know
it should somehow provide privacy
protections i don't i think it's outside
of the scope of differential privacy
right
yeah yeah okay
next one is also on the privacy theme
isn't differential privacy pretty
useless in medical applications in that
the noise added
overwhelms the data okay so so
um so good question so
in in all of differential pro like every
differential privacy result
um pretty much has the following at
least if it's on like showing how to do
some particular calculation
in a differentially private fashion has
two parts
like a privacy guarantee and a utility
guarantee
and the privacy guarantee basically says
like well if you add this much noise
to the computation this is like the
amount of differential privacy that each
individual has promised
and then the utility part basically says
well
as a function of the amount of noise you
added in part one
here is the utility guarantee but
basically
the utility guarantee basically gets
stronger and stronger
the larger the data set is okay and so
in particular
a typical rate is
would be something like one over the
square root of the number of rows in the
data set
right so in other words um if i have n
medical records and i'm trying to build
a predictive neural network for some
disease based on these
medical records um the
accuracy i'll get in my predictions will
kind of scale
like one over square i mean the error
that i'll get in my predictions will
scale with like one over square root of
n
so so it's not just that you have
privacy guarantees you have
accuracy guarantees and a rate which is
is nice as a function of the sample size
so
so i think the way i would put it is if
you've got a big big medical database
like a large hospital like penn would
have
you can actually do practical things
with differential privacy
while providing strong privacy
guarantees
but you do need a reasonably sized
population
and that's why that's the way the
deployments we're seeing
are you know on you know by companies
like google and apple
who have you know huge numbers of users
or entities like the us census so
you know i don't think differential
privacy is a viable
privacy solution if you've got a medical
database of like 100 or even a thousand
records i think you need
something closer to 10 000
yeah so just picking out another another
question in the batch
um what in your opinion are the
limitations of differential privacy
yeah okay so i think it's a good
question
um
so if you look at the literature on
differential privacy
like the theory behind it is a very
strong and beautiful and in many ways
reminiscent of you know in an earlier
era the literature on public key
cryptography
right we have very strong algorithmic
primitives we have very strong
privacy semantics and guarantees we have
you know very nice um kind of
algorithmic properties like
composability if i give you two
differentially private algorithms
i can take the output of one and give it
as the inputs the other and that
pipeline still obeys differential
privacy
um so all this good stuff i think the
main
difficulties with it are engineering
difficulties okay so
in particular the biggest engineering
difficulty with differential privacy
is you know what goes by the name of the
privacy budget
okay so let's take again a medical
scenario where
i want to use your medical record to
build a neural network for some
you know disease prediction problem okay
and so i
i add a certain amount of noise to that
computation and then you have a certain
guarantee of differential privacy
if i now do another study also including
your medical record
to predict something else and i add
noise to that
um your privacy guarantee you still have
a privacy guarantee but it's degraded
and it's basically degraded nicely in
in the sense that it's linear right so
you know you have
basically half as much prime you know
like
you you have it's additive basically
okay so the one
practical problem with this is in
settings where you don't know in advance
how many computations i might want to
perform on somebody's data
okay and so in particular one of the
earliest commercial deployments
of differential privacy was by apple who
used it for in for the somewhat
whimsical application
i think they were just trying to dip
their toe in the water in a low stakes
area
was to basically have your phone in a
kind of randomized response manner
report noisy usage statistics of emojis
so like you know how many times this
week did you use the
you know the the crying heart emoji how
many times did you use this or that
emoji
um and and so they were basically having
people's iphones report these noisy
usage statistics
in a differentially private manner but
they had to basically
you know program the phone for how much
noise it was going to add each time it
did this
okay and you know when some
some serious specialists sort of looked
at their implementation
and kind of asked apple like well you
know tell us more about the choices you
made
you know basically apple answered well
what we did is we just like we basically
pretended
that every month you know we kind of
flushed everything we knew about a user
before and we just reset their privacy
budgets to zero which you kind of can't
do
so i think you know in applications
where there's going to be kind of
ongoing continuous
querying or analysis on some underlying
data set
and you don't know in advance how many
such computations you need or want to
support
i don't think there are great
engineering solutions to that i mean
basically
you have two broad choices you can
either basically say like okay
i'm going to allow queries up until some
privacy
budget limit and then i'm going to cut
everybody's access off
or you can just start adding gradually
more and more noise which kind of has
the same effect right because
once i'm adding so much noise that it's
overwhelming
like the signal in the data it's like
i've taken away your access to the
database
the one kind of holy grail of
differential privacy that actually a
bunch of us have been
working on a lot experimentally that
bypasses this problem
is the idea of um differentially private
synthetic data generation
so the idea is i take an existing
private database
and rather than you know picking some
computation i want to perform on it
um and then doing that that computation
in a differentially private fashion what
i do instead
is i actually create a noisy synthetic
version of this data set okay
um that promises a certain level of
differential privacy
and then i release that to the world and
everybody can do whatever they want on
it
forever okay now the trick there
is you know when i sort of create this a
noisy synthetic database
i have to commit to what statistics of
the original data set i want to preserve
right because that's the nature of the
optimization problem you're solving
you're basically going to say something
like look
i want you to find a synthetic data set
right with like fake numbers in it that
maintains
certain statistical approximately
maintain certain statistical properties
of the original
okay um and then once you release that
anybody can do whatever they want to it
forever because by the way one of the
other very nice
algorithmic properties of differential
privacy is
differential privacy is irreversible so
in other words
um if i do a differentially private
computation
no amount of post-processing of the
output of that computation
even combined with other data sets that
might become
available even in the future can undo
the differential privacy
right so it's it's it's sort of like a
data processing
inequality kind of thing um from
information theory for those that are
familiar with it
so so the nice thing about
differentially private synthetic data
generation is you
do once and for all this synthetic you
release once and for all this synthetic
data set and people can do whatever they
want to it
the the problem is is that you know what
which and this is the kind of thing
we've been trying to work on it's hard
is wouldn't it be nice if i could kind
of preserve
enough statistics of the original data
set
that all of the standard operations of
machine learning
would give you more or less the same
results on the synthetic data set
that they would have on the original
data set approximately
okay but it's not easy to sort of write
down
like a simple optimization problem that
somehow
captures preserve all of the standard
operations of machine learning
and so the empirical question is whether
if you just
ask for kind of enough but not too much
you might get for free on at least real
data sets
the preservation of much more than you
explicitly demand
and so these are kind of but but
everything i'm saying here is very much
a you know active frontier of current
research
moving on to some of the the fairness
questions
lev asks about the green orange
population example
says it seems unconvincing with respect
to race because if the
explanatory variable for the difference
is access to resources
or i guess you know more generally
something correlated with the forbidden
attribute then using the this illegal
attribute of race would not be needed to
have a good classifier
um you know what do you have a better
example of this causing a problem
um so so let me
agree with the hypothesis but basically
say that the type of fairness definition
that i'm talking about here you know
is kind of inheriting the entire mantle
of modern machine learning
which you know largely ignores causality
right so so i agree here that you know
in the example that i've given
race is kind of a correlate of some
underlying
causal source that you'd like to address
or adjust for
um and there are causal approaches to
fairness
um you know as you can imagine causal
approaches to fairness
in machine learning are no easier than
causal approaches to machine learning
period right it only gets more
complicated
and so there are such approaches um and
there's a lot of very recent research in
this that i'll admit i'm not
entirely up to speed on so there might
be advances that i don't know about
but but the problem is just from an
algorithmic standpoint
compared to these more types of
aggregate notions where you're just
basically saying look
these are the variables i can measure i
don't have access to the underlying
causal explanation for the disparity in
sat scores across different racial
groups
but i can measure race right and
and i'm just going to try to correct as
best i can
i agree it's flawed but the the causal
alternative
is you know is also kind of largely
much less practical and actionable um
from an algorithmic perspective
all right there's one here about um
uh also about fairness you said the the
social norm needs to be well defined
uh very precise to be used within the
algorithm
uh say we take this norm to hire females
given equal qualification what would you
need to implement that
into an algorithm aside from deciding
what equal means and what features
should be looked at
could just repeat the last part again uh
what would you need to
implement such a social norm
so hiring females give an equal
qualification
in an algorithm
well i mean assuming you had some
definition
of what you meant by equal
qualifications
and you can measure gender then
conceptually it's straightforward right
you would basically
say um i want to find an algorithm
which you know again part of the goal
here is to
create repeatable processes for
designing algorithms right
and so the repeatable process that you'd
want to
enact here is similar to the one i gave
in this college admissions example which
is
you know you basically say like well um
i'm going to first lay down
a fairness consideration right which is
that you know pairs of individuals one
of whom are
is male or female and that they have
equal qualifications
the rate at which they're getting hired
should be the same
okay um now in this particular case this
notion of equal qualifications right
actually
is a little bit different than the
statistical notions that i mentioned
because the statistical notions like you
are not represented accepted
as a member of your group right so just
in case it wasn't clear
you know if i'm doing consumer lending
and i basically say i want to make sure
that my model doesn't
falsely reject black people for loans
at a much higher rate than it falsely
rejects white people
um you know if you are a black person
who is
actually falsely rejected for alone by
such a model
your comfort is supposed to be the
knowledge
that white people are being falsely
rejected for loans at the same rate
as black people okay but it's cold
comfort for you
in this example of kind of equal hiring
rates for equal qualifications
you need a little bit more nuance of a
definition that comes closer to the
individual level
right because you want to make pairwise
comparisons you want to basically say
if i have two applicants and they're
roughly the same
except for their their gender then the
chances that they're being hired should
be about the same
and there are individual fairness
definitions in the literature and
some of them um are kind of
algorithmically
tractable as well but not all of them so
one would kind of need to get into the
weeds a little bit on
exactly what the features of applicants
that you were going to use
for determining kind of equal
qualifications and you need to kind of
commit
to some sort of metric for that but but
these individual fairness notions
have that metric no flavor to them they
basically say
something like look um if i'm going to
make a prediction about two people
um and i have some notion of the
distance between these two people in
some
similarity space the the typical type of
individual fairness definition says
the difference in the difference in the
way i treat these two individuals
has to be less than sort of some
function of the distance between those
two individuals so in other words
nearby or like individuals have to be
treated similarly
by my predictive model and so it's a bit
trickier than these group fairness
definitions but you can in many cases
again write these things down as um
you know constrained optimization
problems and think about solving them in
various ways
right and and um
another question i guess i guess um
follow-on question about using um
attributes of protected classes um
taylor says in focusing on the output
instead of the input in regards to
fairness couldn't having inputs like
race gender and sexuality being known
from the beginning
be harmful for people who are biased
against i guess be harmful because
people are biased against those
protected classes
um racism homophobia or other prejudices
that exist how do you protect
that specific data being from being used
in the wrong way
yeah so it's a good point right so if if
the reason right for excluding those
types of protected attributes
um from let's say loan applications
was because of an earlier era where you
know you were worried that human beings
who might be racist for instance
would look at that information and
misuse it to make racist lending
decisions
um you know to the extent that that's
still a possibility
or that there might be other uses of
this
data that are outside of the sphere of
building like a fair lending model
there might be good reasons to restrict
access to that data so i'm not making a
blanket statement
that you know we should always
willy-nilly allow
everything to be collected by big tech
companies forever
because we have fairness definitions
that can prevent
unwanted influences of those attributes
at the output
i was i was making the much more limited
statement that if what i'm trying to do
is you know direct a machine learning
algorithm to build a model
that um doesn't discriminate by race
in its decisions in some quantifiable
way
that's twofold there's no
harm in allowing the model to use
those sensitive attributes as inputs
because i'm explicitly
policing the thing that i want at the
output and i'm enforcing that constraint
and b as the as per the example i gave
right there really can be settings where
i need
that information in order to prevent the
harm that i want to prevent
i would also no no there there are
nuanced settings and these come up in
regulatory
areas as well and um
and one thing that i'm still not clear
on despite asking
several people that i think should know
more than i do because they're kind of
in the regulatory industry
it's not clear to me whether in let's
say consumer finance
it's clear that it's forbidden from
using race as an input
in any kind of lending decision human or
or algorithmic
it's less clear to me what the
restrictions are on
lending companies gathering that
information in the first place
i think they often do not but but
one thing i would point out that that
having that data
is often a prerequisite just to auditing
your model for discrimination in the
first place right like
if i have a model and not only does the
model not look at race
but i don't have any data on race
then it's very difficult for me to
determine whether my model is racially
biased
right because the most obvious thing i
would do is i would you know
i would take a bunch of people from one
race and a bunch of people from another
race and try to see if there are
statistical differences in the false
rejection rates
and so you do see people trying to do
proxies for that where you know
unfortunately in the us zip code is a
pretty strong proxy for race
um certain jurisdictions like voter
rolls in north carolina indicate race so
you can go
you know if you've got enough customers
in north carolina you can use
vote you can marry your data with voter
rolls in north carolina
um but but like you know i agree it's
more nuanced about the different
settings in which you may or may not
want
access to these sensitive attributes
so um we're almost out of time but just
quickly there
to to parapher paraphrase a few
questions about
interpretability um what what's
difficult about
formalizing interpretability what are
the distinctions between explainability
and interpretability
maybe tell us a little about these are
all good questions
so i think and again i'm going to
express you know kind of our
subjective opinions on these topics
there's there's good work being done in
these areas
the first you know the first thing that
one needs to do
is basically say like well what is it
that we want
an interpretation or an explanation of
right
and there's many distinct things we
could want we could want
you know a hang on a sec let me
rid of this
we could for instance want an
explanation of the data and where it
came from in the first place
we might want an explanation of the
algorithm
that takes the data as input like an
explanation of that propagation
we might want not that but an
explanation
of the model output by back propagation
or we might want
an explanation or interpretation of a
specific decision made
okay um and you know
people have realized that it's important
to make these distinctions
i think our view of what the greatest
kind of missing research
in these areas is behavioral right so in
particular
like all of this all of the kind of
prevailing definitions of
interpretability or explainability
have a bit of a received wisdom quality
to them right
so like in the worst case right um
sometimes you'll see people say like oh
i'll tell you what i'll tell you what
interpretable means interpretable means
a
a linear model with sparse integer
coefficients
okay so you know like i agree that's
some notion of simplicity
but why should an ordinary person find
that to be a satisfying
definition of interpretability and where
is like the
behavioral research demonstrating that
some wide swath of society
or even some small swath of educated
society
finds that to be a satisfying definition
so i really think that the words
interpretability and explainability
they they they invite you to think about
the recipient
of the explanation or the interpretation
and i think that good definitions need
to account for
like things like the level of numeracy
you know so
like if i was asked to explain you know
back propagation in neural networks to
somebody
you know that already has a firm
grounding in
you know statistics and linear
regression that's a relatively easy prop
proposition if i'm trying to explain it
to somebody who didn't finish high
school math
it's a very different proposition and so
i feel a little
i think we feel a little bit like people
are you know kind of tossing definitions
around
without anybody testing like do real
people
find this to be of a satisfying
interpretation
um and you know there are some
so some interesting ideas that i think
are well meaning like you know shapley
values kind of
um you know taking an idea from the you
know the core in game theory and
applying that to the features in the
training of a model
and you know but again i think that
that's kind of an effort in linearizing
things it's sort of like
well if i had a linear regression model
i could just kind of look at the weights
on the variables and that could give me
some sense for which features were more
or less important
but now i have this deep neural network
so i don't know how to do that but
there's this other experiment i could do
but even if i kind of accept that as a
legitimate way
of trying to linearize explanations
nobody's kind of said why the linearized
explanation
is satisfying in the first place and so
it feels like there is kind of
missing behavioral research right right
no that's fascinating
um we're going to have to um stop it
there there are there are many more
really
fascinating questions and it's a really
um
you know interesting discussion but we
run out of time um
you've certainly given us a lot to to
think about michael thank you very much
for that
for that uh talk and and thanks to the
audience
um that was really um quite
quite fascinating a great set of
questions and we hope to see you all
again soon
thanks very much thanks everyone for
coming in great questions